[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
تايمز تنقل عن مصادر ان استهدافهام
بمسيرات تم من اراضي ايران والحرس الثوري
يتهموا اسرائيل
اذربيجان تخلى موظفي بعثتها الدبلوماسيه
وعائلاتهم من ايران بعد يومين من هجوم
المستهدفه سفرتها
وفي بريطانيا سوناتا تحت الضغط
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا هذه النشره من اخر
التطورات المتعلقه بزياره وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه الى المنطقه وصل الى القاهره
وذلك في مستهل جوله للشرق الاوسط تتضمن
ايضا اسرائيل والضفه الغربيه في محاوله
للتوسط لتهدئه وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
كانت قد اشارت الى ان بلنكن سيتشاور مع
الشرك بشان عدد من الاولويات الاقليميه
والدوليه بما في ذلك العلاقات الفلسطينيه
الاسرائيليه والتاكيد على حل الدولتين
للصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
اذان من ردود فعل تاتي بعد ايام التصاعد
التوترات في القدس رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو قال ان حكومته
ستتخذ سلسله خطوات ردا على الهجمات
الاخيره هذه الخطوات كما راينا تشمل
الاجراءات ضد منفذ العمليات وعائلاتهم
تعزيز الاستيطان ونطاق حمل الاسلحه وهو
معتبرته فلسطين بانه عقوبات جماعيه عنصريه
نتنياهو اكد ان اسرائيل لا تريد التصعيد
لكنه اكد الجاهزيه لمواجهه اي سيناريو
اكاديميه مول
المزيد معنا من القاهره مراسل العربيه
تامر نصره اهلا بك تامر طبعا نحن نعلم ان
الزياره رسميا اييه تبدا في شقها الرسمي
تبدا غدا ولكن دعنا
ننظر الى هذه الزياره بصوره عامه الخارجيه
تتحدث عن ان بلنكن في المنطقه ليناقش مع
الشركاء الاولويات في مصر اين تنصب هذه
الاولويات بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه
بالنسبه للقاهره في هذا الشان سواء كانت
موضوعات اقليميه او موضوعات تخص السياسه
الخارجيه المصريه ودور الوسيط يتقاطع بين
الدولتين بصوره كبيره سواء بما يخص القضيه
الفلسطينيه او ليبيا او السودان او ربما
هذا ما دعى الامريكيه لاصدار همم وثيقه
بالاضافه بطبيعه الحال يعني كنت على وشك
ان اقول لك على موضوع اسد النهضه همم لان
هذا الموضوع بالذات واضح ان كان هناك
تراجع كبير للدور الامريكي في همم حتى همم
ربما ان يعني هذا ظهر من تكرار تعيين
مبعوثين للقرن الافريقي مبعوثين رئاسيين
للقرن الافريقي
سنه او اقل من سنه وبعد ثلاثه اشهر
والانهار كما يقول المحللون المصريون لم
تظهر له كرامات اذا جاز التعبير همم
فبالتالي هذا من الموضوعات التي سوف تتم
مناقشتها همم وايضا هذا كان من الموضوعات
التي تم فتحها خلال القمه همم الافريقيه
همم في واشنط التي شارك فيها الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي همم الرئيس السيسي
بالمناسبه همم يعود اليوم من ارمينيا
وبالتالي كما ذكرت المقابله سوف تكون غدا
وتليها مقابله وزير الخارجيه المصريه
الموضوعات الاخرى الاقليميه همم طبيعه
الحال تتمثل في الدعم الامريكيه همم
للجهود الامميه لتحقيق المسار السياسيه في
ليبيا وايضا لاستعاده همم المسار السياسي
بقياده مدنيه في السودان طبقا للبيان
الامريكيه او اللي وثيقه الحقائق التي
صدرت وكذلك التزام الدولتين
بحل الدولتين كساس كحل الصراع العربي
الاسرائيليه هنا يعني يبدو من خلال
المحللين المصريين بعض التشاؤم في هذه
النقطه تحديدا همم اشير هنا الى مقال
كتباه همم الكاتب عبد الله عبد السلام في
جريده الاهرام وهي جريده مملوكا للدوله
تحدث فيها عن المعايير المزدوجه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في التعامل او التعاطي
مع الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على جنين مقابل
مثلا الهجوم على الكنيسه اليهوديه
فبالتالي همم هو ليس لديه امل كبير في هذه
النقطه وان كان يشير الى تكرار زيارات
المسؤولين الامريكيين في الاونه الاخيره
سواء من قبل همم
برنس المدير الاستخبارات الامريكيه والان
قابلينكن واشار هنا الى انه ربما يكون
الموضوع المطروح هو ايران هذا لم ياتي ذكر
في همم وثيقه الحقائق من الخارجيه
الامريكيه ولكن جاء ذكر له خلال بيان
السفاره الامريكيه منذ ثلاثه ايام عندما
اشارت الى الملف الايراني كذلك يعني
لانه التشاؤم همم من جهه الجانب العربي
فيما يتعلق بالم فالامريكي ربما اسرائيل
ايضا لديها نوع من التردد حول طبيعه
الموقف الامريكي وان كان هناك في نوع من
المقايضه فيما يتعلق بايران مقابل تحريك
الملف الايراني وبذلك استطيع الانتقال
الان ينضم الينا من القدس مراسل العربيه
زياد حلبي اهلا بك زياد ما المتوقع لنبدا
اسرائيل من هذه الزياره بالنسبه
لاسرائيل تحاول عمليه رد الضغط الامريكي
في الموضوع الفلسطيني لجهه المطلب
الامريكي من اسرائيل وهو مطلب متكرر
سبعاته مرتين في سبيع الاخيره مره من
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي ومره من
رئيس السياحي الذي يزور اسرائيل والاراضي
الفلسطينيه
وستسمعه للمره الثالثه
على اسرائيل ان تكون حديثه جدا في التعاطي
مع الملف الفلسطيني بسبب التركيب المتطرفه
للحكومه الحاليه بمعنى ان الولايات
المتحده قلقه من امكان ان تنساق الحكومه
او نتنياه وراء الوزراء المتطرفين لجهه
المحاوله ضمن المستوطنات في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله او القيام بامور
تجعل حل الدولتين مستحيلا بشكل نهائي
بالاضافه الى ضروره
افضل تصعيد مع الفلسطينيين التحذير
الامريكي عمليا الذي سمعته اسرائيل من
انها تعلم جيدا بانها تحتاج الى الولايات
المتحده بخصوص ايران وبالتالي عليها الا
تفسد العلاقه اكثر ااا وان تتيح للولايات
المتحده العمل معها في الموضوع الايراني
من خلال من خلال خفض الموضوع الفلسطيني
ومحاوله ربما هل حاله الامور طبعا
التركيبه لهذه الحكومه لا تتيح همم مرونه
للامريكيين بشكل كبير لكن عمليا هناك ارث
من التوتر في العلاقات
بشكل شخصي وبين هذه الحكومه والحكومه اقصد
والاداره الديمقراطيه بين اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده وبالنسبه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه ربما العلاقه وان كانت احسن من
همم سابقتها فيما يتعلق بالترامب ولكنها
لازالت ماذا عن علاقه المصريه الامريكيه
همم تامر
العلاقات المصريه الامريكيه هي يعني علاقه
ممتده دخلت العام الاول بعد المئه همم منذ
ان تم تاسيس العلاقات الدبلوماسيه ربما
ستكون هناك حديث عن التعاون الاقتصادي
وخاصه ان هناك التزام بين الدولتين بتشكيل
نوع من اللجان الاقتصاديه المشتركه لتعزيز
مثل هذا التعاون الخارجيه الامريكيه ايضا
امتدى حتى قيام مصر ببرامج الاصلاح
الاقتصاديه واخيرا همم ما يتعلق
بالقرض المقدم من صندوق النقد الدولي فهذه
هي المناقشات التي من الممكن ان تحتل هذا
الموضوع للتاكيد على المسار الذي تسير مصر
نحو همم الاصلاح كذلك هناك علاقات متشعبه
جدا في ما يخص المساعدات العسكريه وغيرها
من الامور التي تتعلق بالدولتين في اطار
العلاقه التي اعتقد فتره طويله الى
المستويات الاستراتيجيه همم
التوقف فيما يتعلق بنقطه الاسلحه لدعم مصر
بهذا الاطار وهنا انتقل لزياد للحديث عن
الدعم اللا متناهي الامريكي الى اسرائيل
رغم كل ما ذكرناه كيف يمكن له ان تطبق هل
بالفعل اسرائيل تشعر انه ما يصرح به
امريكيا كدعم كامل يطبق على الارض
بالنهايه
لاسرائيل هذا لا يتغير عاده ميسون ولكن
عمليه هناك الان همم ثلاث مواطن همم مواضع
ثلاثه مواضع قلق لدى بلينكن همم في حياه
الاسرائيل في سيناقشها في هذه الزياره
الموضوع الاول هو قضيه عدم مفاجاه اسرائيل
للولايات المتحده في الموضوع الايراني
نقصد بذلك طبعا الضربه الاسرائيليه
المستقله للمنشات النوويه الايرانيه هذا
مصدر قال لك لدى الامريكيين امريكا حاليا
تعارض هذا الموضوع الامر وطبعا اسرائيل
تعلق ما زالت قلقه من اداره لانها تشك
دائما في ان هذه الاداره ترغب في العوده
الى الاتفاق النووي بشكل او باخر لو تسنى
لها ذلك غدا صباحا الامر الاخر هو القلق
الامريكي مما يحدث داخل اسرائيل
ما قاله ويليامز ايضا بان الانقلاب كما
يسمى
بالقضاء في اسرائيل سيضعف قدره واشنطن على
حمايه اسرائيل على الحلبه الدوليه لان
القضاء الاسرائيلي امر مهم في هذا الموضوع
لمساعده واشنطن الموضوع الثالث الذي هو
مصدر التوتر الذي سبق وتحدتنا عنه
والموضوع الفلسطيني فيما يخص الدعم
الامريكي العسكري لاسرائيل اسرائيل تريد
تقصير الجداول الزمنيه في قبرين اثنين
تسلم طائرات تزوج الوقود في اسرع وقت ممكن
وتسلم ايضا قنابل خارقه للتحصينات في اسرع
وقت ممكن طبعا لا نحتاج الى ذكاء خارق
لمعرفه ان ذلك للتحضير للضربه على المنشات
بموضوع متعلق
لان الحرس الثوري يلتهم فعل باختصار زياده
لا حاليا في اسرائيل لا لا تعليق على هذا
الموضوع طبعا مصادر في مختلفه الولايات
المتحده من قامت بهذا الموضوع وليس
اسرائيل
مراسل العربيه تامر نصره شكرا جزيلا لكم
[موسيقى]
الفلسطينيه موجه من التصعيد هي الاعنف منذ
تولي حكومه نتنياهو زمام السلطه في
اسرائيل
39 قضوا برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي في مخيم
جنين نهايه الاسبوع وبعدها بيوم واحد قتل
سبعه مستوطنين برصاص فلسطينيه في القدس
مرحله ما قبل الحرب بخطوه فقط
هذه المعركه وهاي المواجهه وهو لان هم ما
خلونا اشي ولا واقع على الارض
الغربيه اللي هو 2002 و 2001 و 2003 هذا
التصعيد يتزامنه مع جهود دوليه تبذل
لتهدئه الاوضاع في المنطقه عشيه زياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
الى تدخل الامن امريكي فاعل
ومؤثر لمواجهه هذا الاحتلال وحمايه مصالحه
وقيمه ومصالح العالم
انتشار المكثف للمستوطنين على الطرق
الرئيسيه في الضفه الغربيه
ومهاجمه المركبات الماره ومنازل
الفلسطينيين القريبه من الشارع
ترافقها دعوات وقرارات اسرائيليه
لتسريع وتكثيف تسليح المستوطنين
تجاوز المستوطنون حد مهاجمه المركبات
الفلسطينيه بالقرب من المستوطنات وتوغلوا
الى داخل الكره الفلسطينيه واحرقوا هذا
المنزل وسط مخاوف الفلسطينيين من تكرار
العمل وايقاع الضحايا ما قد يؤجج الاوضاع
اكثر من بلده الترمس خالد القاسم
العربيه
باطلاق الجيش الاسرائيلي النار على سوريين
حول التسلل من حدود الجولان المحتل قال
مراسل العربيه ان احدها هؤلاء قتل والاخر
يعاني من اصابه حريجه من جهته قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان السوريين كان مسلحين وحاول
اجتياز انسياج الامني في الجولان المحتل
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
اوكرانيا تنتظر قرار ان امريكيا لتزويدها
بمقاتلات اف 16
والمانيا تبقي الباب مفتوحا للحوار مع
بوتين
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه نكمل من
الايران وتحديدا من ملف استهداف مواقع
عسكريه ايرانيه بمسيرات في محافظه اصفهان
فبينما قالت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ان هذه
المسيارات يعتقد انها انطلقت من الداخل
الايراني اتهمت وسائل الاعلام تابعه للحرس
الثوري الايراني اتهمت اسرائيل بالوقوف في
خلف هجوم اصفهان وهددت وسائل واعلام
ايرانيه تابعه طبعا للحرس الثوري حددت
اسرائيل باستهداف مصالحها بالمسيرات
راموس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بالعمل الجبان عبد الحيان اكد ايضا ان هذه
الهجمات لن تستطيع التاثير على تطوير
المجال النووي في ايران بحسب تعبيره
[موسيقى]
على كل معنا من الرياضه البحث في الشان
الايراني صالح حميد اهلا بك استاذ صالح
اسمح لي ان ابدا باخر التصريحات التي وردت
على العواجل قبل قليل نائب الرئيس
الاوكراني وجه كلمه لايران قال فيها بانه
منطق الحرب لا يرحم حذرناكم هل يمكن قراءه
هذه التصريحات بغض النظر عن من قام بهذا
الاستهداف بانها تحدد الرساله الرئيسيه من
وراء الاستهداف
نعم يعني هناك البدايه يجب ان نقول ان
تناقض في الروايه الايرانيه وزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه البارحه صارت
باصدار بيان حذر جدا قالت
مسيرات استهدفت الموقع ولم تكن للخزانه
اعتقد ان الامر عكس من ذلك كان هناك خسائر
كبيره على ما يبدو العديد من الفيديوهات
يعني اظهرت من اصفهان ان هناك حريق
الهائله كانت هناك انقاذ
وسيارات اسعاف ايضا تناقض التصريحات
والتهاب الجهات المختلفه همم توحي بان
هناك همم شيئا كبيرا خاصه
بس خلينا نقرا المشهد احنا لانه المعلومات
الدقيقه غير متوفره لدينا همم هناك
تصريحات واضحه وصريحه فيها نوع من
التحذير الواضح والرساله المباشره من
اوكرانيا وبالتالي يمكن ان نربط ما حدث
هناك مباشره بملف المسيرات في اوكرانيا ام
لا انه هذا موضوع وهذا موضوع او ربما
تتلاقى المصالح بهذا الاطار
لا حزال واصل دعم روسيا بالمسيرات وهناك
حتى عن صواريخ تريد
روسيا وتستخدم في الحرب ضد الاوكرانيين
لكن ايضا يجب ان نقرا توقيت هذه همم
العمليه والتي جاءت يوم امس بعد ساعات من
همم معرض حضره المرشدي لا لا عليه خامني
وكان هناك وحدات تطوير همم المسيرات
الايرانيه وهي النسبه التي تستخدم في
اوكرانيا همم يعني هذا ايضا يذكرنا قبل
عامين عندما حضر همم حسن روحاني همم معرض
همم لاجهزه الطرد المركز المتطوره وتم
ايضا استهدافها بنفس اليوم وكلها همم
رسائل الى ايران لانها بان الجهات سواء
كانت اسرائيل او الولايات المتحده لم تسمح
لها بتطوير اسئله
داخل الايراني بعمق كونه عم نربط بعد
الامور ببعضها البعض والمصالح متشابكه
والعداءات ايضا متشابكه بهذا الاطار همم
رصدنا عمليه تحدثنا عنها قبل قليل عن
اثنين على الحدود من الجولان المحتل في
محاوله لدخول اسرائيل هل يمكن ربط هذا
ايضا بذات بمعنى اخر اذا كانت ايران تتهم
الحرس ايران او الحرس الثوري يتهم اسرائيل
بذلك فربما هذه ايضا رساله بانه ايران
قادره على تحريك احدى الجبهات
بالطبع ايران تريد هذا اصلا منذ صباح
اليوم صرح مستشار الفريق التفاوض الايراني
لانه اسرائيل لم تهنئه باسبوع هذه واا
ستكون هناك عواقب لهذا العمل وهمم احدى
الرسائل هي
الايرادات نقل ما التغطيه على ما يحدث في
الداخل من احتجاجات ونقل لهذا الصراع الى
الخارج وتريد ان تقول انها في مواجهه مع
اسرائيل لكي تبرر ما يحدث في الداخل من
القمع
بالتاكيد لكن الجميع يعلم ان هذا الصراع
مستمر خلال السنوات الماضيه همم مسؤولين
ايرانيين انفسهم اعترفوا بانه هناك اختراق
الاسرائيلين على اعلى المستويات همم في
همم منذ عام 2018 عندما تمت سرقه الارشيف
النووي والنقل الاسرائيلي وخرج حينها
نتنيها وعرضها على التلفزيون وبعد ذلك تم
عده استهدافات في المواقع والمشئات
العسكريه وان الايراني التي طالب لكم
اكثر من اطار واخرها ربما يمكن قراءه
العاجل الان البنك المركزي الايراني يقول
انه تم انشاء خط اتصال بين البنوك
الايرانيه والروسيه وربما يمكن مناقشه هذا
الموضوع في اشتركتنا اللاحقه من الرياضه
الباحث في الشان الايراني صالح حميد شكرا
جزيلا لك
نبقى في ايران وبعد الهجوم الذي طال سفاره
اذربيجان في العاصمه طهران طبعا قبل 48
ساعه اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الاداريه انها
ستجلي موظفي سفاراتها في طهران وافراد
عائلاتهم ردا على الهجوم والذي اسفر عن
مقتل حارس امن واصابه شخصين ووصفته
العاصمه باكو بانه عمل ارهابي ايران من
جانبها حاولت احتواء الازمه باعتقال لشخص
يشتبه بصلاته بالهجوم لكنها ذكرت انه يبدو
ان وراء هذا الهجوم دوافع شخصيه وزاره
الخارجيه اذربيجان كانت اعلنت بعد الهجوم
انها استدعت السفيره الايراني في باكو
للمطالبه بتحقيق عادل
ايران تاريخ من الاعتداءات على السفارات
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه عام
1979 اقتحام السفاره الامريكيه بتهران
امريكيين لمده 440 يوم عام
1987 اعتداء على مقر السفاره السعوديه في
طهران عام
1988 متظاهرون يهاجمون السفاره الاتحاد
السوفيتي حينها عام 2009 متظاهرون
ايرانيون السفاره الباكستانيه في طهران
عام 2011 اقتحام السفاره البريطانيه
عام 2016
وائل التطورات الحرب اوكرانيا حيث قال لك
رملين انه لاتفاق على محادثات مع المستشار
الالمانيه
محادثه هاتفيه اخرى مع الرئيس الروسي وفقا
لصحيفه
مشيرا الى ضروره واهميه المحادثات معه رغم
اختلافه وجوهات النظر بين الطرفين حول
الحرب الروسيه
الى اوكرانيا حيث وصفت تقارير التي تتحدث
عن ذلك بالسخيفه
المزيد معنا من موسكو مراسله العربيه
كاتيا طعمه اهلا بك كاتيا اصداء هذه
التصريحات شولت في موسكو
مرحبا بك ميسون بالفعل يعني المستشار
الالماني كنا قد شهدنا له مكالمات هاتفيه
مكثفه في العام القادم مع الرئيس الروسي
الذيمر بوتين على الرغم من ان العلاقات مع
المانيا ليست في احسن احوالها وبالتحديد
الان بعد ان اعلنت المانيا انها ستقوم
بارسال دبابات لمساعده كيف طبعا وتزويدها
بالسلاح وهذا طبعا ما كانت تتعلقت عليه
موسكو وقالت انه يؤثر سلبا على العلاقات
المستقبليه بين روسيا وبين همم بين
المانيا منذ قليل كان قد تحدث الكريم لان
الرئيس الروسي القديمه لا يزال منفتحاا
لاي مكالمه او لاي حديث مع القائد او
زعماء الغربيين وبالتحديد هنا على تعليقا
على التصريحات التي صدرت عن المانيا بان
مستشار الالماني ينوي اجراء محادثه هاتفيه
مع رئيس الروسيه
الزعماء الغربيين كنا قد شاهدنا ااا
اتصالات مكثفه ايضا من الجانب الفرنسي في
العام السابق من اجل طبعا الوصول الى حل
مال الازمه الاوكرانيه طبعا وحتى الان
روسيا وموسكه هي طبعا عندما موقفها ثابت
لانها ستجري في العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
حتى النهايه لتحقيق اهدافها التي بدات من
اجلها ميسون
المتعلقه
بسخافه ما ينشر من انه المانيا يمكن ان
ترسل طائرات الى اوكرانيا هل لها ان تهدئ
ايضا همم من التوتر ما بين المانيا وروسيا
بعد ما ذكرتيه فيما يتعلق بالدبابات
اه حقيقه روسيا تعتبر ااا ان النت ودول
الغربيه والمانيا بالتحديد هي الان بدات
بمشاركه بشكل مباشر في هذه الحرب على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بارسالها الزخم الكبير
من الاسلحه ولكنها من جانب اخر كانت قد
ادلت في تصريحات على لسان مسؤوليها بانها
همم لا تظن انه سيكون هناك طبعا تزويد
بطائرات او بمقاتلات لكيف لان اصلا روسيا
هي تسيطر على الاجواء الاجواء الاوكرانيه
ولا طبعا دخول اي طائره سيتم قصفها من
الجانب الروسي كما حدث في وقت سابق طبعا
روسيا كان قد دمرت الاسطول الحربي القوات
الاوكرانيه خلال العام السابق في همم اطار
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وعندما نتحدث عن امكانيه اجراء هذا الحوار
الجديد مع شولت ماذا يعني
في اي اطار يمكن ان يكون هناك نوع من
التقدم اذا كانت المواقف لا زالت على
حالها من قبل الطرفين كيف ينظر المراق الى
ذلك
يعني كما يتحدث بعد الخبراء من الصعب الان
تكهن ماذا يحمل مستشار الالماني من
مقترحات للرئيس الروسيه بلادي ميركوتا
وبالاخص ان موسكو حتى الان لا تنوي ان
تقوم باي تنازلات في اطار هذه العمليه
العسكريه وبطار المحادثات ايضا روسيا كانت
قد قالت مرارا انها همم
فتحه للحوار مع الكيف ولكن طبعا وفقا
لشروط التي تضعها موسكو وهي طبعا عدم
التنازل عن شبه جزيره الكرم او تنباس
وبالتالي من الصعب الان تكهن فيما اذا كان
هناك يحدث تقدم في حال اتصل همم المستشار
الالماني برئيس الروسيه او همم اي زعيم
اخر من الزعماء الغربيين همم سواء كان
رئيس الفرنسي ايضا الذي اعتدنا انه يتصل
بشكل صحيح بشكل مكثف في الثانويه في السنه
السابقه العربيه
[موسيقى]
على الصعيد الميداني قالت وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه قالت ان الوضع في الشرق صعب
لكن هو تحت السيطره وقبل ذلك اعلن الجيش
الاوكراني ان قوته صدت هجوما في منطقه
ابله دانتي في الجزء الشرقي من منطقه
دوناتس جاء الاعلان في وقت قالت فيه جماعه
بابنر العسكريه الروسيه تطبيق تلغرام انها
سيطرت على تلك المنطقه نتحدث هنا عن له
دانتي وبشكل كامل
من جانبيه اعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ايجور كوناشينكو ان انظمه الدفاع
الجوي الروسيه قد اعترضت 16 او 6 10 قذيفه
من راجمات الصواريخ مارس والخا واوروجين
كما اسقطت انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسي خلال
يوم واحد 14 طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه في
دونيسك ولجانسك وخرسون كما قال ايضا ان
القوات الروسيه دمرت محطه طائره دار
امريكيه كي الصنع اضافه الى مستودع ذخيره
اخر
فيما يتعلق باسلحه الغرب التي تسعى كيف
اليها قبل معركه شرسه يتوقع ان تكون في
الربيع قال الممثل الرسمي لقياده القوات
الجويه للجيش الاوكراني يوريغانت قال انه
في الاجتماع المقبل لوزراء الدفاع نيته
بالمانيا
بشان توريد الطائرات المقاتله نقلت وسائل
اعلام اوكرانيا نقلا عن اجانت مطالبته
باستبدال اسطول الطائرات السوفيتيه
باكملها والذي اصبح بالفعل متقادما على حد
وصفه مؤكدا ان هناك حزمه جديده من
المساعدات العسكريه التي ينتظرها الجيش
الاوكراني من حلفائه الدوليه
ومع زياده المطالبات الاوكرانيه بشان
تسليحها بمعدات غربيه حديثه يضغط عدد من
المسؤولين العسكريين الامريكيين يضغطون
على البنتاجون للموافقه على ارسال طائرات
اف 16 الى اوكرانيا في وقت لا تزال واشنطن
متردده بشان هذه الخطوه
في اوكرانيا
يسعى من خلالها الرئيس بلادي ميرسي الى
تحويل المساعدات الغربيه من اسلحه دفاعيه
الى هجوميه تحصبا لمعركه الربيع القادم
بعد دبابات تيليو بارتول الالمانيه
والبرامز الامريكيه طائره اف 16 ملكيه
الصنع على قائمه اولويه زيلانكي التي
يراها الوسيله الوحيده للتصدي لهجمات
الصواريخ والطائرات بدون طيار الروسيه
لازاله هذا الخيار للغازات لتدمير المدن
الاوكرانيه باستخدام قاذفات الصواريخ
منتشره
صحيفه بوليتيكو الامريكيه كشفت عن ضغوط
تمارسها مجموعه من ممثلي وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه سرا على البنتاجون للموافقه على
ارسال طائرات مقاتله وصواريخ بعيده المدى
الى اوكرانيا
وفقه مراقبين فتغير منحى المساعدات باتجاه
الاسلحه الهجوميه يمكن ان يغير معادله
الحرب الدائره منذ نحو عام تقريبا فمع
الاستعداد لتنفيذ هجوم الربيع من طرف
الجيش الاوكراني اكتسبت توريد المحتمل
لطائره اف 16 زخاما كبيرا فالطائره تنتمي
الى الجيل الرابع من المقاتلات الحربيه
وتعد من اهم الطائرات الحربيه المقاتله
خفيفه الوزن فسرعه الطائرات تصل عند اقصر
ارتفاع لها الى اكثر من
2400 كم في الساعه كذلك يصل متوسط عدد
ساعات الطيران للطائره الواحده خلال عمرها
الافتراضي الى حوالي 12,000 ساعه طيران
تقريبا
بدت كيف اكثر عملا في ان تاخذ واشنطن
قرارا حاسما بشان تزويدها ب f16 لذا اعدت
قائمه تضم 50 طياره يمكنهم بدء التدريب
لتكون مستعده لمعركه الربيع
المفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان واللجنه
الدوليه لصليب الاحمر دعته الى مطالبه
السلطات الاوكرانيه بالالتزام باتفاقيه
جنيف وذلك على خلفيه تعرض مستشفى في بلده
نوفويداد
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه الامر الذي
اعتبرته او اعتبره الجانب الروسي انتهاكا
صارخا للماده 18 من اتفاقيه جنيف بشان
حمايه المدنيين في وقت الحرب
في الخميس ولكن بعد قليل
تراجع قياسي في مبيعات الهواتف الذكيه
بالصين
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه اكد نائب رئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين
في مقابلاته مع العربيه اكد ان العراق
بحاجه الى علاقات صحيه وطبيعيه مع الدول
الخليجيه مع الولايات المتحده ايضا
بالاضافه الى ايران مشيرا الى ان العراق
يجب ان يقرر سياسه علاقاته الخارجيه على
ضوء المصلحه العراقيه وحدها
في العمل مع الدول الغربيه
الاقليميه المحيطه بالعراق نحن بحاجه الى
العمل مع الدول الخليجيه الاعتماد
المتبادل سواء في الاقتصاد او السياسه او
الامن موجوده في في موجوده في في العلاقات
الدوليه اذا نحن بحاجه الى علاقات صحيه مع
هذه الدول العلاقات الطبيعيه مع هذه الدول
والعراق يجب ان تقرر سياسه العلاقات
والسياسه العلاقات تقرر على ضوء المسرح
العراق
هناك مصالحه اقليميه واخرى لكن بالنتيجه
المسرح العراقيه تقرر سياسه العلاقات
العراقيه معدوله اخرى من ضمنها الولايات
المتحده
قال انه بالفعل هناك تهريب للدولار
الامريكي من السوق العراقيه وهي مشكله
ليست جديده
للدولار الامريكي من السوق العراق العراق
بتنظيم العرض وتنظيم الطلب اذا
مساله العرض يخص اجانب العراقي او
المؤسسات الماليه العراقيه من ضمنها البنك
المركزي وجانب الامريكي لكن مساله الطلب
هذا غير شيء اخر
اعلن وزير الدوله لشؤون الاقتصاديه بحكومه
الوحده الوطنيه التي يراسها عبد الحميد
سلامه الغويل عن انسحابه من الحكومه حسب
ما افادت التلفزيون المسار الليبي واوضح
ان السبب في هذا الانسحاب هو ان الحكومه
لم تغير تعبر بالاحرى عن الوطن بكامله
مضيفا ان الحكومه تعبر
نتيجه الظروف والانقسامات الراهنه
قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك
رئيس حزب المحافظين ناظم الزهاوي من منصبه
في الحكومه
تحقيق مستقل بخصوص شؤونه الضريبيه الى
ارتكاب الزهاوي لخرق جسيم لمدونه السلوك
الوزاري المتعلق بالضرائب حينما كان وزيرا
للماليه
الزهاوي من جانبه قالت طبعا تعليقا على
اتهامه بالفساد قال انه سمعته تعرضت
للتشويه دعونا متابعه
الوكاله الوطنيه
لكن منذ ان تولى ريشي سوناك رئاسه الحكومه
في اكتوبر الماضي طبعا خلفان للاستراس وجد
نفسه في الداونلود امام تحديات حمل بعضها
التراث التي اتهمها بارتكاب اخطاء جسيمه
لكن هل سونات قادر على معالجه الفوضى التي
خلفتها تراس بحسب ما يرى سوناك تعهد
بقيادته حكومه قائمه على النزاهه والمهنيه
والمسؤوليه حسب قوله ولكن في اقل من ثلاثه
اشهر وجد ان الطريق الذي مهده للنصر بدا
يضيق وفقا لصحيفه الجارديان الصحيفه
البريطانيه قالت ان القرارات المعيبه التي
اتخذتها تراس وحتى من قبلها بوريس جونسون
ما زال تطارد حكومه السوناك وتحديدا حزب
المحافظين الحاكم فلا توجد رؤيه اقتصاديه
واضحه في الافق حتى الان ناهيك عن تكاليف
المعيشه المستمره في الارتفاع وما صاحبها
من اضرابات عماليه واسعه وخلال فتره وجيزه
خسر سوناك بالفعل وزيراين قبل ويليام سان
الذي اتهم بالتنمر على موظفي الخدمه
المدنيه واخيرا رئيس حزب المحافظين الوزير
نديم زهاوي بسبب فضيحه ضريبيه تحديات تضعه
امام متاعب يتعين عليه تجاوزها سريعا اذا
ما اراد لحومته الا تجد نفس مصير تراس
وجونسون
المزيد معنا من لندن المراسله العربيه
ريما مكتبي اهلا بك ريما اسمحيلي لان ابدا
بتصريحات الزهاوي التي قال فيها بانه
سمعتوا تتعرض للتشويه هذا متعلق مباشره
بطريقه اقالته كان ممكن تفادي ذلك من خلال
ربما اجباره على الاستقاله او لا الموضوع
يتعلق بما يسار الان من حوله
سهام الهجوم ووجه ااا ناظم سهاوي للاعلام
ان هناك محاوله
لتاثير على سمعته عوضا ان يعتذر وعودا عن
يعني ان يوجه هجومه على رئيس الحكومه وصفت
طريقه اقالته بالبروتل
اي مشاعر كان قاسي جدا ريشي سوناك لا يريد
ان يتهاون مع الاخلال بالسلوك همم
الحكومي
والتوهم ناظم زهاوي بهذا الموضوع ليس فقط
لانه وزير الماليه وهنا اريد ان اشرح انه
وزير الماليه هو رئيس شعار رئيسيه يعني
هيئه الضرائب ولكن ااه القضيه بدات بلسان
2021 يعني قديمه عمرها سنتين بدات الهيئه
الضرائب تحقق مع ناظم زهاوي
ليه تاخروا او عدم دفعه ضرائب عن مداخيل
تاتي الى بريطانيا لم يصرح بانه تحت
التحقيق وهنا المشكله فقبل مناصب حكوميه
من وزاره التعليم اخر شيء كانت وزاره
الماليه
وزاره التعليم وغيره ولم يعلم اي من وزراء
الحكومه الذين عينوه بانه تحت التحقيق
ريش السوناتا ريما
اه بس لكن ميسون يبدو انه كمان عمليه طعن
بالظهر لانه بالظهر لانه هلا في حكي عن
انه بولس جونسون هو البديل لا ااااه ناظم
زهاوي اذا هناك اقاويل وهناك ما اخذ على
ناظم زهاوي دفع خمسه مليون جنيه
لدفع المبلغ المستحقه لهيئه الضرائب 30%
من الخمسه مليون هي جزيه او جزاء او
بانيلتي عن تاخره بالدفع يعني لا شك انه
اخطاء بموضوع الضرائب لكن اكيد فيه عمليه
تصفيه الحسابات فقط جونس انه ممكن يكون
بديل هو مثل رد
الصاعقه
من قبل
هاوي طبعا بظهره لمكان رئيس حكومي ايه
يعني همم اكثر من مره ولم ينسى برج جونس
هذا الموضوع تصفيه حسابات بس ريما كيف
يمكن ان يؤثر ذلك على صوره ريشه سوناك
يعتبر انه بواجبه او انه هذه ضربه جديده
ربما تضاف الى المشكلات القائمه والتحديات
لحومته
مثل ما بتقولي ميسون ضربه جديده ليش لانه
اصلا بريطانيا تعاني بشكل كبير نسبه
التضخم كبيره جدا همم هناك الكثير من
المشاكل الحرب في اوكرانيا كلها تؤثر ليس
فقط قرارات الاسراف لم تحكم وقت طويل لكن
تتراكم المشاكل على بريطانيا وريشي سوناك
لم يكن بحاجه لها كذا خطا بحكمته وهذا لن
يساعده ابدا ولا لن يساعد ايضا حزب المحقق
كان السؤال الاخير بس على كل الجواب عليه
ريما مكتبي مراسله العربيه من لندن شكرا
جزيلا لك
اعتبر الامين العام لحلفي شمال الاطلسيه
التجارب الصاروخيه التي تقوم بها كوريا
الشماليه ضربا من ضروب الاستهتار جاء ذلك
خلال لقائه بوزير خارجيه كوريا الجنوبيه
في سهول المتابعه
والبرامج النوويه لكوريا
معا في مجالات مثل التكنولوجيا
الالكترونيه
تراجعت شكرا لعبد الله تراجعت مبيعات
الصين من الهواتف الذكيه
13% على اساس سنوي ليسجل هذا القطاع اكبر
انخفاض خلال عقب في ظل تقليل المستهلكين
لحدود الانفاق يعود ذلك بسبب تقارير الى
الضوابط الصارمه لمكافحه كوفد في الصين
التي القت بثقلها على الاقتصاد الذي تراجع
العام الماضي الى اسوا مستوياته منذ ما
يقرب من نصفي قرن
اعلنت السلطات في افغانستان ارتفاع حصيله
الوفيات نتيجه البرد التي لا تزال تعصف
بالبلاد منذ 20 يوما الى اكثر من 160 شخصا
اشارت السلطاته الافغانيه الى ان موجه
البرد هذه تعد الاشد منذ 15 عاما
رقم
اطفال يقولون لي اذهب واحضر لنا الحطب لكن
ليست لدي نقود
ولا ينتبه لهم المجتمع الدولي سيكون من
الافضل لو تمت مساعد هؤلاء الفقراء والا
سيموت الكثير من البرد
يجب على المجتمع الدولي النظر في ظروفنا
غالبيه الافغان يعانون من ظروف الاقتصاديه
صعبه نرى هنا ان معظم الناس يجمعون
بلاستيك لتدفئه انفسهم
[موسيقى]
ان اكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه الخامسه شكرا
متابعه مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]